Potatoes are native to the Americas.
In fact, there are over 3000 varieties in
the South American Andes alone.
Now in the 1600s and 1700s, European explorers
took potatoes back to Europe where they were
cultivated and they quickly became a dietary
staple, especially in Ireland.
There the farmers found that on their small
plots of land, potatoes gave larger and more
reliable yields than grains.
And pretty soon the average Irish peasant
was eating between eight and 14 pounds of
potatoes per day, from which they derived
about 80 percent of their daily caloric intake.
These nutritious potatoes helped reduce infant
mortality and led to a population explosion
in Ireland.
The population actually doubled from four
million to eight million between 1780 and
1840.
So potatoes supported a whole new group of
people in a way that was never before possible.
But then in 1845 a fungus spread across Europe
destroying almost the entire Irish potato
crop.
And the fungus was particularly devastating
because there was really only one variety
of potato in Ireland, the Irish lumper, and
it had limited genetic diversity.
And so within five years one million Irish
people had died and a further one and a half
million had fled the country.
Now YouTube is a little bit like a potato
in that in the 10 years since its inception
it has made possible a new way of life for
thousands of people including myself.
And for that I am incredibly grateful.
YouTube and you who have watched my videos
have made it possible for me to pursue my
passion, making science films.
But if there is a lesson we should learn from
the Irish potato famine it is that depending
on only one source for your livelihood puts
you in an incredibly precarious position.
And starting today there is a new potato,
or new video sharing platform called Vessel
on which I will also be launching my videos
in addition to YouTube.
Now Vessel will charge a three dollar monthly
subscription fee in order to get exclusive,
early access to videos before they are posted
on YouTube.
But if you sign up in the next three days
you will get free membership for a year and
no credit card is required.
So if you want to check it out, click the
link in the description.
Now if you don’t want to sign up to Vessel,
that is completely fine, too.
I will continue posting my videos as usual
here on YouTube.
The idea with Vessel is to generate more revenue
for creators by offering this exclusive early
access.
It is a bit like how movies are launched first
in cinemas and then on DVD and finally on
TV.
Now will this work?
I have no idea.
But you know my feeling about risk.
And, in this case, I think it is worth taking
a chance.
So if you want to take that chance with me,
then click the link in the description or
head over to Vessel.com/science.
Now Minute Physics and Minute Earth will also
be launching first on Vessel and we all decided
to use a joint link, Vessel.com/science.
So when you sign up via that link, you will
be supporting all of us, Veritasium, Minute
Physics and Minute Earth.
You know, I think that having more diversity
and competition in online video is a good
thing.
It will lead to more stability for creators,
more resources that I am going to use to make
bigger and better videos and, ultimately,
more tubers for YouTubers.
That was not washed.
Unwashed potato.
Nutritious.